well to begin with and this happened
when i was in graduate school i
had a lot of bad habits i smoked like a
pack of cigarettes a day and
i drank a lot i came from this little
town in northern alberta and
like many little towns especially in
northern canada
that alcohol overuse is de rigueur you
know it's
it's and so um i noticed when i was
in my early 20s that the only time i
really regretted what i had done
was when i was drinking
now it was also interfering with me
writing
because i couldn't concentrate well
enough if i was hungover but i also
couldn't really constant i couldn't
i couldn't tolerate the emotional strain
of what i was writing about when i was
hungover it was too
i couldn't handle being on the edge
because i destabilized my nervous system
in any case i stopped drinking and the
reason for that was well
i decided i didn't want to be ashamed of
what i was doing anymore it seemed
i thought well maybe i could not do
things that were shameful
and then see what my life was like
so chapter two is imagine who you could
be
and then aim single-mindedly at that and
and for me after being on tour with you
um i think that's something that that
got into me through
osmosis that i would be on stage and
even though everyone was there for you i
thought
hey i'm part of this somehow this this
thing
somehow i became part of this and then
once i realized
that when the pa announcer said my name
that those people knew me i thought
that i'm me i'm the guy they're talking
about like i'm doing something and then
it that just that it helped my aim
it helped my aim and i wonder how many
people just don't
they don't know how to aim because they
have no experience like that
something like that well that's that's
part of what tradition is supposed to
teach you by presenting you with
examples of great people of the past
the lesson is not supposed to be exactly
bow down and worship these people
be like them be like them
and you could be and i mean that's
really the goal of the humanities when
it's the humanities if it's not
if that's the goal then students will
study the humanities
as soon as that ceases to be the goal
then
it it there's there's nothing of value
there
i mean great literature tells you it
tells you the great story of good and
evil
always it's good and evil against the
background of chaos and order
always and the evil characters are there
to
to to be bad examples and the good
characters are there to be good examples
or you see the interplay of those forces
within a single person
and and and it's a reminder of of who
you could be
and you you can find out who you should
be it's actually
this and this is something quite
mysterious i believe and
and part of the proof let's say that we
exist in a world of value
your conscience tells you who you should
be
now that doesn't mean that necessarily
that it's infallible but
people wrestle with their conscience you
know there isn't anyone i've never met
anyone who is
you know i'm not i'm
narcissists accepted let's say
people are generally tormented by their
conscience and
the reason for that
is that they're not
they're deviating from the path that
is their destiny i mean if you don't
think that well then what do you think
what do you think that conscience is
i mean i've asked my classes repeatedly
do you have a little voice in your head
that tells you when you've done
something wrong or you're about to or a
feeling
and they all they all immediately agree
with that no one finds that a foreign
concept and so
if you don't know who you are your
conscience will remind you when you're
no
sorry if you don't know who you could be
your consonants will remind you when you
deviate and then
you can start to attend to that think
well look
i'm actually ashamed when i do this
i should stop unless i want to be
ashamed all the time it looks like i
should stop
and then maybe you stop doing that and
and then your conscience subjects to
something else and maybe you stop doing
that and
as that happens you start to develop a
vision of who you
could be and the chapter indicates
it it it it it looks at symbolic
representations
it's an examination of a certain
symbolic representation of the ideal
and so it's my attempt to um
assess tradition for what it can tell us
about what the ideal human being might
be like
and the ideal human being is the person
who forthrightly
upholds the traditions of the culture
and forges away into the unknown
we went through that and um and
pulls new information in and builds
rebuilds himself
and the world and that's who you could
be and
now the the the difficulty comes in
figuring out how to do that within the
confines of your own life so in some
sense that's how to bring the divine to
earth
there's this divine pattern but it's
it's general see this is one of the
mysterious things about christianity
that's so remarkable about it is that
there's
there's an there's the the the christ
that's eternal the word of god say so
that's
it's a representation of something
absolutely transcendent
but it's married to the particulars of
one particular time and space and
obviously
um critics of christianity regard that
as one of
its major flaws you know that there's
this idea of
god who is a carpenter in some out of
the way
place in some out of the way time
but you're someone in an
out of the way place at a particular
time and place
and for for you what that means is that
for you to make contact with the highest
of values
you have to bring that down to your
particulars
and figure out how you do that it's
going to be a way that no one else does
it because you're
the only one that's you and but you can
you can aim at something aim at
something and the the point of the
chapter is that you aim at something and
that will shape you as you move towards
it
and then your aim will change you'll
move but that doesn't matter
it gets you going and you'll be molded
across time
more and more into the person you could
be
can you talk about that just from a
personal perspective as someone that
i've seen do it i mean i i that's what i
saw you do every night you would take
your your intellectual um curiosity to
to the end of where it would go
sometimes you would get off stage
and say to me oh you know i i took that
as far as i could tonight
and then the next night you would go a
little bit further with it or a little
bit further and i knew
there were moments because we did so
many shows i knew when you were
a little past where you would want to go
and then i could see you
come back but can you talk about what
that was like for you
in terms of your life how you felt how
time felt how
the relationship with the audience felt
when you're when you're doing it right
because i feel like people don't know
that when you're doing it right what
does it feel like
well to begin with and this happened
when i was in graduate school i
had a lot of bad habits i smoked like a
pack of cigarettes a day and
i drank a lot i came from this little
town in northern alberta and
like many little towns especially in
northern canada
that alcohol overuse is de rigueur you
know it's it's
and so um i noticed when i was
in my early 20s that the only time
i really regretted what i had done
was when i was drinking
now it was also interfering with me
writing
because i couldn't concentrate well
enough if i was hungover but i also
couldn't really constant
i couldn't i couldn't tolerate the
emotional strain of what i was writing
about when i was hungover it was too
i couldn't handle being on the edge
because i destabilized my nervous system
in any case i stopped drinking and the
reason for that was well
i decided i didn't want to be ashamed of
what i was doing anymore it seemed
i thought well maybe i could not do
things that were shameful and
then see what my life was like so that
that was sort of on the negative end the
constraint end
i think people get on the more positive
end people get
deeply involved in what they're doing if
they're in the right
place in the right time so that you i
would say you can tell
this is the idea of heaven on earth to
some degree
when time stops when you're not aware of
the duration of time
when you're so engaged with what you're
doing that you're not aware of the
duration
of time then
then you've got the forces of chaos
balance and order balanced
properly it's you're not stultified and
bored
that's an excess of order everything's
too predictable
you're not overwhelmed you're you're
dealing with
it's like it's like it's you're playing
tennis at the peak of your game that's
partly what people experience when
they're great athletes when they play
the zone yeah you know when they're
always stretching themselves to their
limit
you can tell that if you watch a gymnast
for example who has a brilliant
performance they've stretched themselves
beyond their domain of competence during
the performance
and that's what makes everybody leap to
their feet that's
that's the incarnation given embodiment
right there in front of you for some
moments and everyone cheers that on
do you think it's weird how it becomes a
fleeting moment in a way like i
know i know i know what you're saying is
true when
i'm when i'm doing what i'm supposed to
be doing and i'm on my game and
and my thoughts are are right and
straight time
just moves and then i go whoa a month
passed a month passed and i was good
that whole time and i
i did write that whole time and i was
happier and my relationship with david
or whoever else is is better in that
time
but that that it becomes fleeting in
that suddenly you could have a great
month and then suddenly something
happens
chaos returns like it's it's that we
almost forget that moment you can't
like you can't hold it well it requires
a lot of
it requires even to some degree some
good fortune to maintain
i certainly haven't been able to do that
while i was ill
you know in time one of the consequences
of
of my illness whatever it was or
is was time dilation like days lasted
weeks it seemed like minutes lasted
hours and i mean that
literally and that was terrible
the weight of time it's the weight of
brute mortality
it's the weight of self-consciousness
and
you escape that immersed properly
so and that that second chapter is a
pretty practical chapter it's like well
if you're not
who you want to be then think about how
you could be better
take a chance aim at that work at it and
see what happens
if you'd like to see more honest and
insightful conversations with jordan
peterson himself check out our jordan
peterson playlist which includes
every interview i've ever done with him
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
both are right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell